some disagreements with them on issues
but you believe in his right to speak
absolutely we are now seeing a major war
on freedom of speech and really actually
demonstrates that there's a greater
agenda going on here yes some of what
Andrew says is controversial but that's
not a reason to cancel someone or
de-platform somebody also a lot of what
he said has actually been taken out of
context many of the Clips re-edited in
order to portray a completely different
narrative But ultimately what we're
seeing here is a massive war on
masculinity because Andrew is empowering
men to take personal responsibility he
actually teaches them how to leave the
system how to leave the Matrix how to
become an entrepreneur to live the night
of Life how to basically save yourself
because nobody is coming to save you how
to become immune from all of this
corruption that we saw and the Tyranny
that we saw over the last two years one
of his most viewed videos on YouTube is
actually how to fight depression without
any pharmaceutical pills which will
basically leave you like a dead zombie
all of this stuff empowers men so of
course he's being